most of the time this is the thing i've
learned over the years never doubt bubsy
man but yeah it's going to be potato
from georgia versus uh complaining from
israel um
we're going to the chicago pali pad this
i've never seen that view of jitsu
before what the hell that's crazy um
but yeah uh yoshi was the king a very
unique matchup once again not one that
we see often yeah yeah it's def yeah
like you said it's not one we see often
but it looks like yeah just
like i said chose war today started off
so strong he is not letting go of king
big whip on the fourth floor
and i believe these guys have played
quite often as well um in grand finals
in a lot in in tournaments so they're
gonna have knowledge against each other
so uh complaints starting off perfectly
there seven golden layers see i wanted i
wanted to make the worst dad joke ever
but i think what was the dad joke i was
like complain can't complain with those
seven calling letters
we're getting older
bro so many people are you know
followers now so you know that jokes may
apply
eleven win streak here four complain
let's see if we can keep that up
okay ultra potato using that trying to
catch him crouching
he's using a lot of mids here you know
trying to keep him in check make sure he
stays respectful doesn't move too much
yeah
they're talking about respect there's no
respect just throws it out there
oh nice duck
yeah this is gonna go to the wall oh god
this is a bad position to be in
okay wait for some kind of setup didn't
really work out but still does have the
rage available need to be very careful
king's race driver is one of the best in
the game up there he's out he's
definitely up there
holy nice
all right complain now two rounds up
very experienced yo she missed playing
the playing for many many a year yeah
just look at that movement it's so slick
oh no break on the shiny wizard though
yeah
okay nice step okay nice start now that
string is it's it's a tricky yoshi
string like you need to be on point and
ready for it because if you press the
button too late and dark you will get
count and hit launch
yeah
this is a much better round here for
ultra interpretation looking to make a
perfect little call out on the spin yeah
using the homing move on the board now
here so that is one of the things that
when you when you're fighting against
the yoshi in this matchup spin obviously
it evades it evades a lot quicker than a
side step besides walk but holding moves
will hit it
okay
where's the wall there's the wall
you've got no soul stop to go to that
seat it's a full launch
okay it goes to the other wall this guy
is a definite character specialist
finding all those walls
because i said that
oh that was
unfortunate oh no i couldn't let it rip
that would have been big damage oh what
the hell's going on here i don't know
what's going on people's elbow what's
the mix up goes to the ground
such a big read there but it doesn't pay
off
ah
he he thought he had the answer there
because
he thought that you were going to stay
on this ground
and you know it would have been the
round he would want he would have won
that round that was such a big read um
yeah i don't agree with it could have
gone for like a down free maybe to stay
a little bit safer but
yeah but i think that in that situation
you know he was looking to get the uh
the win sometimes when you're when you
have such a massive life deficit you
have to take risks right true and i
think in his in his mind he was like
okay i've got to keep on taking risks
even though at the end he kind of didn't
have to right but um he was in like
panic mode he was in fight or flight
mode you know he's like okay i need to
go i need to go with him it was an ultra
instinct you know it was an ultra
instinct but it didn't work for him it
didn't it wasn't perfect to ultra it
wasn't the white hair it was the it was
like okay
unfortunately
and i actually kind of missed super you
know i know people didn't like it uh you
know what you know what before people
start counseling me again like
i'm not an anime specialist all right i
just i didn't watch it like because i
know people get really get into it and
they're like no but his power level was
this yesterday like no i just watched it
but as it was didn't it like i i
instantly just watched it
and i enjoyed it right there i got a lot
there's a lot of complaints i thought oh
the art wasn't good awesome please don't
shoot me down guys i enjoyed it okay
please please laugh you gotta cancel
bobby again how dare you calling at the
lower bracket now you're saying db super
was good twit longers guys everybody
twit longest please allow me i'm new to
this i'm just coming back please i like
that all right here we go
we're on the uh the howard estate now
let's see what um ultra instinct can do
here this is a stage that actually if
they don't go for the forgotten realm
they actually do end up going to this
one so let's see can make a difference
you get amazing combos on this stage
especially you know with those three
wall bases very unique stage in the
sense that i don't think we've ever seen
a tekken stage with three wall base oh
gosh keeps it going yeah i kept going in
okay look at that that's the massive
difference right we didn't see that in
the in potatoes last match against devil
um
but yeah he wasn't he wasn't breaking
those throws
okay
okay oh here we go now this is now this
is a three-way mix-up okay go for the
sharp shooter this time because i'm a
nerd i know that's a one break
okay nice
is that could you break that because it
was um yeah
so in that situation i think with that
back turn with that grounded throw he
gets another
attempt
so i think that other temple's
guaranteed if i remember correctly i
haven't played king and ages
okay
nice looking better here for ultra
potato those ground floors really worked
out there
yeah it's funny because that's how we
lost a match last grand
game you going for that ground pro
nice and you know that hop knee it not
only crushes lows but it has a bit of
height evasion as well and look at that
beautiful complaint back on the board
even in it out here
straight back with that that was a solid
round from complaints take it back take
that momentum back for ultrasound
doesn't want him to get anything started
yeah okay down back three okay okay go
to the hopkins try to keep him cv was
respecting the downward three plus
frames
[Music]
straight into that
you see how he sidestepped as well to
kind of realign himself with yeah it was
really good and i like the way he kept
the combo nice and short make sure
you've got the guaranteed damage there
okay now
complains okay completely trying to back
away from the wall
okay but uh oh nice
nice and this should be around yet to
keep it nice and simple go for the
running powerbomb ender
round four oh yeah really just answering
back i'm liking this
count to hit the start off this round
now altering the video will be able to
take this into the corner here now this
is a very dangerous position for
competitiveness he guesses wrong on that
as well fifty percent got it here comes
the chain throw oh oh russian left sweep
he's gonna go for the arm bar
oh no what's the mix up
oh cause i mean here okay i'll give corp
and a second hit is this gonna be seven
golden live
okay
patience
there so in that situation
yoshi can keep doing i think it's crouch
slash one he can keep doing that and
he'll keep flipping but i guess he
thought that he's going to tech because
if he if he goes to that crash dash one
and you text it's basically you're
you're going to get launched because
he's going to take it you're mad open
but if you take it you're going to take
straight into that suite so he's playing
that mind game right there saying that i
think you're not going to stay on this
ground you're going to take because you
don't want to eat this so
let me out my heat with this tech trap
but you guessed right there on the okay
yeah and of course that flip over the
crash dash one cd one it didn't do a lot
of damage anyway it doesn't hurt too
much and you had a massive life yeah
i'll just stay on the floor if he tries
to go for one of the other options to
catch my tech roll then it's going to be
an easy punish and i'll get the round so
yeah i mean like i said one thing about
ultra insane potato is he's a very clean
player he makes he just stays composed
and he makes really good decisions
because he's just a experienced player
you saw how many matches he's got in
just playing match we don't even count
rank that's just playing that man that's
just the player match yeah and that's
just wins not even losses not even kind
of the losses right so thousands and
thousands of matches and of course the
georgian scene is a scene that is
definitely going to break out offline
soon because they not only have
alternative potatoes they have a lot of
other very strong
players as well
you know very very fundamentally solid
players and their offline scene is is
pretty strong just like i was talking
about jordan how they have a small
offline scene georgia has the same thing
um so that's why we're seeing these guys
you know compete here in the top level
yes i'm talking about this is definitely
top level games here because
me i love to see the mind games in the
middle man games and we saw it there at
the end of that match where you know it
was just deeper than technology it's
just you know we're really getting into
the mental mind games there and that's
when i think tekken is at its best
yeah so here we go
all right there we go complain starting
off stronghood one match apiece the
throws coming out here from potato and
there's a first reaction here now
because it's winners finals what's going
to be the okie dokie well so jericho
goes to the ground floor again but
doesn't wake up in time
nice side step pocket that's the second
time he's done that means be successful
but misses on the fourth one tail spin
there
yep
but okay nice on the spin but was very
patient there didn't press the button
[Music]
yeah
the reason why that giant was so hard to
break is especially after a dash is
because it looks very similar to a
shining wizard right so a lot of people
press one plus two because i think it's
a running running throw i i would press
one plus two i would have eaten yeah i
would have got flunk across the stage
nice phrases correctly on the three-way
mix-up
[Music]
okay
so you can punish that but if you if
you're a little bit delayed you're going
to get counter hit right there so you
need to be on point there ultra into the
tail just wasn't ready there i would
have been ready for that either you just
kind of free out there you know yeah
quite sleeping at the world yeah talking
about i talked about throwing out there
here comes the launch it drops it again
the ford forward one he's dropping his
combo set nice back dash but it doesn't
get the beat
he could have got a hot knee there but
you know any damage is better than no
damage there and again on ford free
looking to end the round
oh no no
complain for the comeback caught by the
rage drive right there using the plus
strains before and then using the rage
drive to lock him down like rage drives
have a really big hurt box so it's
they're kind of hard to step
yeah no we're harder to step let's say
that you can't
okay we're seeing good movement here
from potatoes sidewalking left which is
the way you want to go generally versus
yoshimitsu yeah
here you go for the giant i'm not
dancing that's the irish rip
um close to the half boston crab because
i'm a nerd and i know these moves yeah
you know all the new the movements
[Music]
all right
all right oh it drops the combo again
get caught coming in with the flash it's
going to be huge damage
yep two tailspins here because of the
rage drive he's even out no punish he
was off axis
sword sweep complain
like i said this man has many many
tricks up his sleeves
complaining bringing them out now it
just seemed like he he was just the fan
favorite in that scramble you got a
little bit
what
caught him oh yeah what an answer there
with the running power bomb
oh god now we've got a bit of a brawler
this is what we wanted to see man okay
come get out of that bro if if you
didn't get out of it then i i would have
been it would have been hashtag play for
can complain code
bro
there we go and that nice what's the mix
up
okay uses the race drive there
yeah that's good good stuff on complain
i mean from our potato just making him
erase his resources yeah
because it's scary as well because when
yoshinis who does have the um
great he actually is one of the unique
characters that has access to two um
rage art and one of them is a flash
yeah yeah yeah
nice well i'm talking about flash there
he went for a flash but um
also it's a potato being very patient
there i was able to punish you
okay a little twitch stuff from
complaining just like hit by them throws
a nice break on the giant so again
complain really showing this good throw
breaking yeah he's saying that he's
really on point there like kings froze
like they they really do wear you down
and you're not really gonna break them
all
yeah
and is that hey
he's not gonna break the move because of
that thing doesn't tech though
yeah so it doesn't um lessen the damage
when you take you you lessen the damage
oh
no what are you trying to heal for bruh
bro why are you trying to heal nice okay
as well rage available complain can you
make another comeback
he's done it before
don't turn your back on me all right
punish -10 nice
there you go it goes close to no sword
so you need to be very careful flash
because i think flash comes out a little
bit faster than this or has a bigger
hurt box it's one of the two
nice put your sword away i will take my
left foot and just put it in your face
you can't do that up for three beautiful
so again you can see around like
complain clearly is is playing really
well as well let's see he's not playing
bad by any means excellent but altering
the potato once again the decision
making the timing is looking very good i
would like to see him punish a little
bit better um because of course there's
there are moves like cd1 which you
mentioned is launch punishable but
you know you need to have a move which
has good range to punish it maybe king's
forward two would be a better oh yeah
there's me trying to move down is that's
one of his new moves his new additions
it's a great addition actually um that
was a great one i was thinking back
three but not four two yeah no
definitely that it's a four traveling
chunky it's a it's a mid right yeah as
well yeah so uh yeah that would be a
great move to use just to whiff punish
in general because it looks like he's a
little bit attentive he's like i don't
want to go for my hop kick punish in
certain scenarios because it might with
well four two if you and it's kind of
confirmable as well in situations it's
like situational comfortable yeah so
that would be a bit better but complain
i feel like we might be getting a final
match chamber because complaint
definitely has a lot more tricks up the
sleeve might be going to an in uh a wall
stage again just to utilize the the okay
mix up stuff
um yoshimitsu when he gets when he gets
to the wall he's got aoki wherever you
tech he's got the sword windmill and
then like we said before we stay on the
ground he's got the crash that's one and
it just becomes a bad
oh match but
what you said bob z this is what you
said man he does have a pool and
it was it was only this week he was
actually playing kane and trench
and kanan trench is one of our strongest
players won many a tournament before and
it was really back and forth
it was really really really back and
forth so it's gonna be interesting to
see um paul like i said that character
it composes a scary character like
there's no one that can tell me that
plays tech and then they're not scared
of a pool when you see a pool in your
bracket you're like
there we go yeah today you know
it could go either way like big man hits
yeah but if you're ultra if your potato
right now you're thinking you know what
i have the advantage here because i'm
winning on on matches and i've made him
such character so definitely in the
driver's seat at the moment oh he's
driving that was a great duck there with
the full couch um down board too it's
going to
nice patience there from ultra instant
potato just avoiding everything so goku
esque i want to say there we go oh
that's good yeah that is a punish there
is it how is that not clean here yeah
that should be a polish right right that
wasn't punished yeah yeah this is weird
that it wasn't a it wasn't a clean thing
i think it's warm i think it's an angle
yeah the weird angle on the wall you
know how walls are spooky you know yeah
you know
what the booty rocks have you got four
i'm trying to go for a a throw
well this guy's playing super solidly
right now nice side step two
this should go to the wall
nice gets to curry
oh that was sick
so when you when you get that side wall
split if you do one two and he's like
ground throw it works as a combo
i learned that from aries actually
yeah
okay range available for potato now good
break that was touch break
no if you get punished get the side wall
splat
so unfortunate three and and that's the
thing about king's back one man it's got
a bit of let you see it again right it's
hitbox is not the best it's definitely
not the best because it's it's a good
car hitting tall but
it can get a bit finicky and just
punish you look like
complain now it's just all over it looks
like this whole pic made
maybe the answer i'm telling you paul is
scary he's a scary character for sure
man i mean he he's doing really well in
this scramble situations and now
potatoes are overextending he's getting
nervous bob see definitely nice side
step just messes up the combo okay hop
kick nice punch on that need to be very
careful because that is a wall break
right
there oh we tried to break the ball i
think okay that sounds very unfortunate
oh no oh no oh no oh no one more hit and
no
should not work
it worked he pressed the button
ladies and gents we are going to be
going to a final round potato one right
away from moving into grand finals here
for this master event he committed to
the that was a
big commitment at the beginning a nice
slow oh get that [ __ ] out of him a nice
low parry there we go
okay what's the pushing towards the wall
good position but no he puts himself to
the wall this is a very bad position
he's gonna get old no he doesn't get a
wall splat but king's in a very bad
position gets the wolf's back now
yeah
oh yes complain oh he doesn't get the
wall combo
that was
i had my i was like this that the
camera's gonna see i had my i didn't
want to see us i was scared
wow just coming back right there
making
what did i say man i feel like i said i
feel like we're going to be going to a
final match because it wouldn't be a
master event without that man winners
finals are going to a first to one now
bubsy the matches have been played out
the information has been downloaded
what does ultra instinct potato do now
the paul is out does he go back to the
howard and say does he go to the
forgotten realm or is it gonna be an
infinite stage i mean what the choice is
very important now it all comes down to
this one match do you think i think i
don't know it's a good i'm thinking
about it like so it wasn't as if it was
like one-sided it was very part-in-mouth
clutch moments there
does he maybe he wants to give himself
to that little bit of an advantage maybe
go to the forgotten realm just so you
can get the big damage you know if he
gets to launch straight into um running
power bomb
that's like on scale damage and then you
get this um the tail spin after but then
again we've said this before it's it's a
double-edged sword sometimes sometimes
you want to live by the sword you want
that advantage
but then you could die by that advantage
as well you know like say paul you i'm
not really familiar i think paul gets
hit he's the downfall one plus two throw
actually becomes a launch right
uh yeah so i mean the thing is poor like
in that situation looking at the match
like how many times
the war messed him up even when he tried
to go for a back one the wall kind of
gave him a bit of a shove and then the
back one whiffed and like so many
situations it wouldn't surprise me if he
goes to forgotten realm how would a
state or even an infinite state here
because uh he just wants to get rid of
that completely get rid of the walls and
play pure tekken this is what the
koreans say all the time koreans say
well if i feel like i'm better than you
at tekken i'm going to an infinite state
statement just outplay you it's a it's a
statement yeah it's it's a statement i
agree like you know
that is i personally think that's the
purest form of tekken you know just and
if they chose such a good stage for it
you know with the with the waters and
that's pure open stage but yeah this i i
can't actually call this match this this
next one is literally neck and neck you
saw it was a
king started with that down one plus two
he wanted war like i said when people
start with big blade launchers like that
they do not want peace they don't want
it you can see man like potato he's
always so controlled so calculated but
at the end there he started to whiff
massively yeah like i think the nerves
can get to anyone right even though he's
so composing he's been in tournaments
he's been in grand finals before he's
won tournaments he won an icfc
when georgia was allowed to compete in
the icf season for yep and you know
he's terrorized a lot of people with his
with his king right but it's because
he's so controlled and fundamental but
even then when complaining he's
experienced that's one thing that's
coming oh yeah yeah you can definitely
see his experience
and he made him he made him falter but
here we go guys what is going to be the
decision what is going to be the
decision here for ultra insane potatoes
such an important one he'll probably be
sticking with the king but what stage is
it going to be going to the g-corp
helipad headband okay
i respect it
it does have the um the wall breaks on
both sides it is a
it's a it's quite it's quite a large
stage once you get the the um the two
windows broken it's also quite uniquely
shaped stage as well so you can get some
nice combos where it's like side wall
splat and then you can get the next wall
so it'll be quite interesting and we've
seen he's like he's done it for a reason
for sure yeah and we've seen it before
because he's had the combos he's got the
sidewalls that he's done double jabs
into the um crouch throw which actually
combos into a throw as a wall
you see it's a situation that that bumps
you where you know you whiff and the
four two one from king would have been a
perfect punisher right and we're not
seeing that right now from potato
nice giant swing i have respect that
wake up giants think um complains not
expecting so much damage uses the plush
stream catching him stepping with the
ford four
oh oh oh
dangerous oh gosh
this is gonna do a lot of damage and
we've pulled that that was a clutch
break
good job keep out
okay this this isn't next hit could
need to be very careful both guys next
hit will basically win and uses i think
that's a punish there yeah that was
funny i feel like that's very polished
about actually i don't know why he did
that but either way you can see on this
stage i feel like paul has the advantage
almost because you can break those about
those those
those walls yeah with the demoman right
yeah that's all he's gonna be careful
definitely once he gets run paul gets
you back on a breakable wall it is um
literally
we said it for shout out to
show you staying down for this one uh
messy guessing bro you used to unless
you guessed it
bro is that you just you can't you just
don't know what to do
oh she's very careful yes he knows about
that
nice i love that from complain stayed
patient yeah it's like in that situation
if you tech like nine times out of ten
you're gonna get moved in your back
so you need to be very careful how you
get up in that situation ultra is a
potato he i think i think he's got the
white hair go through now he's
definitely stepped it up
yeah he's he's making decisions that
don't make sense to us but they're
working out for him man no break on that
throw all trains a potato nice
okay but complain definitely not out of
this nice side sit there evasive throat
gets to the wall big damage here
okay needs to be very careful like we
said before because the duct there oh oh
my god okay i think it went on four two
one where is it there it is there we go
oh whoa whoa oh oh no i thought he was
going to remove splat again
potato what a comeback
beautiful clutch there three runs
straight will move into the grand finals
bubsy damn that was that shining wizard
was so instant just came out like
complain was just
not not ready